it's after 9 p.m in our nation's capital
and that probably means that
joe biden is likely fast asleep it's
been an exhausting few days for joe he
signed a record
40 executive orders and actions into
quote law after just nine days in office
in other words
he has tripled the amount of executive
orders
signed by trump obama and bush combined
at this point in their presidencies
now instead of the unity that was
promised joe is
literally acting unilaterally to enact
every aspect of his radical socialist
agenda and he's doing it all with the
stroke of a pen and its consequences
are severe it's so bad even the new york
times editorial
board ever so gently and ever so
politely
encourage biden to ease up on the
executive orders
and at least try to acknowledge
there are three branches of government
you're the executive branch then we have
this other branch the legislative branch
and even this ever so mild criticism of
biden
it caused many on the radical left they
became unglued completely
unhinged how dare the new york times do
that
get scores of these blue check mark
liberals on twitter
lashing out at the new york times one
frequent msdnc
guest calling them cowardly another
left-wing activist
calling them moronic by the way when
democrats are busy fighting each other
just let the fight go on how dare the
times write anything other than
glowing praise for their dear comrades
and weak leader
and of course this op-ed does pal
greatly in comparison to how
they covered donald trump and other
conservatives
first in his first few weeks of office
one headline reads
mr trump's threat to europe's security
another quote mr
president trump's reckless shame game
seven months into his term the times
read an article
titled the failing trump presidency
wow that was quick and sadly this is
about
so much more the media bias because with
the stroke of a pen
that's it a pen bioden's litany of
executive orders
are causing real serious
life-changing problems for tens of
thousands of hard-working men
and women our fellow americans right
here and right now they are
suffering thousands already receiving
their pink slips
after joe canceled the keystone xl
pipeline
stop border wall construction up to 58
000 more could soon be unemployed
because of
this new ban on hello these are high
paying
yes blue collar high skill
jobs gone not easily if at all
replaceable all with the stroke of the
frail weak joe
biden's hand a pen in his hand
socialist congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
she thinks this is great what a great
day i'm not making it up
you know i'm feeling extraordinarily
encouraged and i think that
the significance of president biden's
executive orders communicates a lot
one is that it really communicates that
he meant what he said on the campaign
trail that he would make
climate change a central priority of his
administration and that he considers it
not just a national security threat but
frankly you know the global matter that
it is
but it also really signifi it also
really signifies
a good faith openness and relationship
to those activist communities
congresswoman with all due respect your
green new deal policies you're bragging
about joes and acting
they've resulted in great american
workers
your fellow americans getting fired tell
me where they're going to work
next week and how are they going to pay
their bills how they're going to put
food on their table
or pay their rent or make mortgage
payments
or car or truck payments how are they
going to pay for health care
or insurance or day-to-day living do you
even care
because i see zero compassion from you
and john kerry and joe biden and people
to judge
and let's see grant home and the rest of
you hard-working law abiding
pay tax-paying men and women working men
and women out of work with all the
promises we want you to get new union
jobs
well the high-paying jobs that
disappeared for example
and congresswoman ocasio-cortez's own
district
remember she ran amazon right out of her
the world is ending and the new green
deal is far more important
she says the world's ending than tens of
thousands of american jobs
the onward march for socialism must be
our top priority well maybe
congresswoman ocasio-cortez actually
thinks that she's saving the planet
and by the way one out of work american
at a time right
and of course in reality this green new
deal
socialist agenda is hurting our fellow
americans
it's hurting the country and by the way
it will hurt the planet
let me tell you how the world is still
whether you like it or not
reliant the lifeblood of the world's
economy is
energy oil gas coal and guess what
people will still be buying it
americans will still be using it and
guess what we'll have to now get more of
it from
well a lot of countries that we view as
hostile regimes you know
russia iran china countries in the
middle east that hate our guts
those would be countries that don't
really give a rip about the environment
either in other words hostile regimes
run by hostile actors around the world
they're going to get rich and powerful
they're doing backflips
they want to send you thank you cards
and pollution
will likely also get worse this doesn't
seem to matter to anybody in the biden
administration anyone supporting this
madness
for example biden's special climate
envoy john kerry
is long flown all over the world he owns
his big private owned jet
causing by the way his own massive
carbon footprint
now congresswoman ocasio-cortez perhaps
you should ask
your fellow climate change supporter
john kerry there's no problems telling
people you're out of work this is more
important
maybe that jet pollutes more in a given
year than most americans will in their
entire lives
now i think maybe you should ask john
kerry if he cares about the client
why doesn't he lead by example how about
he orders that his private jet be
grounded
and in fairness don't sell it because
there'll still be a carbon footprint
he should have it disassembled so it can
never be used again then you can recycle
all the materials
and while we're at it all of biden's
cabinet officials
they should stop using the private jets
and you might not know this
but you the american taxpayers paid for
it you foot the bill
for what is a fleet a massive fleet
of private jets and aircraft used by
federal officials and cabinet members
now think about it if we're currently
facing this great climate crisis and
congresswoman ocasio-cortez is right
we've only got 12 years and it's that
serious
that oil and gas workers are going to
lose their high-paying career jobs and
lose their health care and maybe lose
their homes and not be able to save for
their future or send their kids to
college
then shouldn't biden officials lead by
example
stop flying on the private jets that we
the american taxpayers are paying for
now i'm waiting for congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
john kerry pete buu to judge joe biden
jennifer granholm i'm waiting for the
answer
i want joe to issue an executive order
grounding
the entire government fleet that we the
taxpayers are paying for
this kind of heartless hypocrisy is
disgusting if you want to be leaders
lead by example they don't care about we
the hard-working men and women in this
country
more specifically those that lost
again good paying well-skilled
career jobs let them work elsewhere john
kerry exclaimed
you know saying it's a worthy sacrifice
a worthy sacrifice according to jennifer
granholm where's her sacrifice
and just go out and find another union
job says
the ever really experienced mayor pete
mayor of south bend
the party who claims to have a monopoly
on compassion for all of us
i'm not seeing much compassion at all
for all these hard-working americans
that are anxious and can't sleep tonight
and worried where the next paycheck is
going to come from
and we're wondering and whether or not
they'll ever be able to replace the good
jobs you just took from them
and remember these job-killing policies
didn't go through congress
stroke of a pen thousands and thousands
unemployed
because joe biden listening to the
radical left that controls him
he did it with the stroke of a pen a few
months ago on the campaign trail
that was biden he was claiming that
governing by executive fiat was
something that
dictators do no we got to get the votes
he said
that is that this is a democracy what
happened joe
case you forgot which is likely i'll
remind you
i got to get the votes i got to get the
votes that's why
you know the one thing and i have this
strange notion
we are a democracy some of my republican
friends and some of my democratic
friends even occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator we're democracy
we need consensus more than three times
the number of executive orders and all
three of
us uh all three previous presidents
biden's press secretary apparently
trying to rewrite history let's take a
look at this lie
does it suggest that president biden
sees himself as perhaps a benevolent
dictator well rob i'm sure this wasn't
your intention but i think you took the
president's comments a bit out of
context he was asked about
tax reform and and whether that could be
done via executive order during the
interview with george stephanopoulos
which you're referring to
but i think well i think that i think
the question is pretty important context
for everybody
and he said no and the president also
said during an interview with columnist
back in december that he didn't think
executive action should be used for
everything and that certainly is his
point of view
three times the executive orders in the
same time frame than bush 43
obama and donald trump jensacke
i thought you were promised you weren't
going to lie to the american people that
would be
um yeah the fact check lie list and of
course
biden's 40 and counting executive orders
don't exactly spell unity do they and
just today he signed off on an order
banning get this top priority the term
china virus in his white house or wuhan
virus from being used at any federal
level
i don't know why even though china and
wuhan
were talking about geographical
locations
you know even though china hate to say
it joe
they were responsible for the virus
remember they put the travel ban in
effect
you couldn't travel out of wuhan to the
rest of china you couldn't travel from
the rest of china to wuhan
but you could travel from wuhan anywhere
in the world
and by the way where is the order
banning the term i guess the german
measles is next
or the new coveted south african variant
of covet 19.
but hey when you're ruled by executive
fiat i guess facts don't matter
debate certainly doesn't matter and
apparently neither do american workers
they're the people that wake up every
day they work hard they play by the
rules they obey the laws they pay their
taxes they raise their kids
they put in there they wake up shovel
coffee down their throat they make the
kids a little lunch for school
they race off to work they do their
12-14 hours
they help their kids with homework they
feed them they put them to bed and they
they literally pass out exhausted every
day
well they won't have that luxury anymore
if this continues
tens of thousands will be losing their
job